in these early days every team hopes
they can triumph over adversity that
same goal also applies to a group of
teenage fans we recently met at a spring
training game in Arizona here's Janet
shamlian
it's fairly typical for players to show
up at Rady Children's Hospital in San
Diego to visit and comfort cancer
patients what's not typical
is for those young patients to return
the favor but there they were cheered on
as they left the hospital
getting off the bus in Peoria Arizona
the spring training home of the San
Diego Padres I think it's inspiring to
finally
just take a break fifteen-year-old
nalene Griffith is battling a brain
tumor at school I think a lot of my
friends and stuff can forget
I've gone through so it's like difficult
without to me every single day here's
what this day meant we're not just
just you know cage up in a hospital bed
a behind the scenes
selfies including from Padre Superstar
Manny Machado meaning Manny it was so
cool Damien Lopez has battled a blood
disorder since birth baseball has been a
part of my life since I was eight and
it's gotten me through some like pretty
tough times
one player in particular hit a home run
with the group I think you guys are
really Brave Padres pitcher Tim Hill
spoke from the heart and from experience
I dealt with the same similar things
that y'all dealt with in 2015 I had
Colin stage three colon cancer Tim Hill
ready here's the pitch Janice swinging
to miss it's like really inspiring he
beat cancer and he still continued doing
what he loved encouraging to me 2-2 hit
up the middle stacked by Hill that helps
me realize that there are other people
in the world that go through the same
thing I do and they made like a huge
name for themselves so I could do it as
well
the day at the Ballpark was an
eye-opener not just for the patients but
also for one of their doctors pediatric
oncologist Jenny Kim just to see the
smiles on their faces at some kind of an
event like this in the hospital there's
not a ton of smiles you know they're
having either procedures or lap draws
and things but I don't get to see the
kids necessarily being their normal
selves outside of the hospitals so for
us the medical people that come along
it's just uh it's also a very Priceless
experience
[Music]
these kids did get unique treatment but
joy came not because the day was special
because it was so delightfully ordinary
it's like I don't have to
for China anymore that like I'm okay
because like I know that everyone else
like understands like how I feel because
they can feel the same way having a good
time
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Janet
shamley
[Applause]
who doesn't love a field trip oh well
yeah but and I I also true and I also
love that line the day wasn't special it
was ordinary delightful no they just
want something you know and just the
idea of them going to a place instead of
being visited at the hospital was just
and you see it's so joy and just at
least for one day they get to be kid
Ordinary People yeah
I went right there if only baseball
parks football stadiums basketball
Arenas would just open up like a hundred
seats for you know kids who are
suffering like this an idea to think
about yeah how about that let's make it
happen